turns out having a cut body doesn't
always cut it with the ladies I can lift
twice my own weight but ladies don't
like that hi hey hi hey hi I'm Fitness
celebrity Rob Dodd Rob Dodd now I'm
gonna show you you yeah how to get a Rob
dog ride add bot get it hey hey hey you
want to get that rad dad bod but you
don't really want to be a dad how do I
get the rad dad Bob hey hey hey see your
dad walking down the street check out
that rad dad's bad bod I want one of
those how do I get one of those sweet
dad bods hey hey hey how do you get that
rad dad bod you want to get that rad dad
bod you want to get it how do I get that
super awesome dad bod get it get it get
it get it
you want to get it how do I get that
super awesome dad bod get it
check out these Rob Dodd rad dad bod
repeatable workout routines I'm Rob
Dodds
Dobb and I'm here to show you Rob Dodds
dad bod move burger flip kick it dad
jokes your old man can be funny here we
go the beer drink cool the sand when
your team wins yeah yeah the baby carry
and cuddle and cuddle what sizing up a
problem and doing nothing
get excited
reading kids a bedtime story don't take
my word for it don't take my word for it
don't take my word for it
sing from the horse's mouth check out
these testimonials technical pick them
out check check check them out check
them out check them out I used to think
I had to work out to be sexy but now I
know I don't have to thanks Rob Dodds
rad dad bods I used to be a virgin but
now I've been on a date
thanks Rob dodge rad bad Bob's to get
robbed does rad dad bods call the number
below whoa check it out go man ever oh
okay wait how do I get a mom bod you
push out a kid well it seemed a lot
harder than what they're doing yeah this
is just laziness and poor outfit choices
remember to sit and drink for 10 minutes
Wow
hey guys what do you think big bands are
coming back